et sa fille Sofia trouvent un peu de
réconfort dans ce poste de police
saviez-vous que c'est mon anniversaire
aujourd'hui lance Sofia à la policière
en guise de cadeau et Laura une tasse de
thé chaud et un peu de chaleur
la pression psychologique est
insoutenable dit sa mère en larmes c'est
l'hiver il fait froid les nuits sont
terribles l'hiver qui s'installe déjà
s'annonce très dur pour le vaincre les
autorités ont déployé près de 4000
tentes on les surnomme d'ailleurs les
points d'invincibilité mensuration les
enfants n'ont rien mangé depuis deux
jours 17 réfugiés arrivés de la région
de harkish ici elle espère trouver de la
nourriture découvertures d'autres y
rechargent leur cellulaire acquiesv le
courant n'est rétabli que deux à trois
heures par jour nous affirme ces députés
les rues sont en train d'immobiliser la
vie dans les grandes villes surtout
ukrainiennes en frappant les les
l'électricité le président volody mers
zellinski affirmé ce soir que plus de 6
millions de foyers étaient encore
plongés dans le noir
critiques dont l'électricité c'est un
aveu de faiblesse dans la mesure aussi
avec des gains militaires sur le terrain
que la réussite à conquérir les
territoires qu'elle dit souhaiter
annexer il y aurait pas besoin de faire
cette campagne de théorles
depuis le retrait des troupes russes
libéré mais détruite la ville compte ses
morts au lendemain d'autres frappes une
quinzaine de civils selon les autorités
peu importe que les Russes vont faire
nous on va continuer à vivre et on va
continuer à nous battre en plus de la
détermination des Ukrainiens Vladimir
Poutine doit désormais composer avec un
autre front celui des épouses et des
mères des soldats russes mobilisés
massivement envoyés au front sous
équipés sous entrée une chair à canon il
les a reçus devant les caméras
officielles
parce que essentiellement la survie de
son régime est très liée au succès
militaire sur le terrain aussi une
affirme que ces objectifs seront
maintenus alors même que le territoire
conquis depuis le début de cette guerre
ne cesserait très cire ici
Radio-Canada Montréal